Turkey Dinosaur? America's original rulers. Merciless beasts, grazing on the flesh of humans.
Then in the 15 century, a vessel crashed. Two vessels really.
Welcome back everyone is going to be my full
Rick and Morty season 5 episode 6 video Rick
and Morty blowing up everything you ever thought
you knew about world history, the history
of America.
So their whole bunch of Easter eggs we'll
break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes were
doing a giveaway for Rick and Morty merge
to all you do to enter is be subscriber and
just leave your favorite Easter egg or reference
in the episode on the video careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet.
I'll just number these as we go along talk
about Easter eggs and moments starting with
the title of the episode.
Rick and Morty's Thanksploitation spectacular
was meant to be a thanksgiving themed exploitation
themed episode that also parodies a lot of
typical TV holiday episodes.
There were a lot of different movie genres
that they parody.
Like they did a parody of National treasure
with the whole heist day-to-day war movie
parody.
They even parodied aliens and predator movies.
They even literally reference the Arnold Schwarzenegger
predator movie at the end of the episode even
felt like when they went full Nazi turkeys
in space they started to do some iron sky
references to just generally a mixture of
a lot of genre tropes and jokes from different
holiday movies and sci-fi movies.
Maybe even little invasion of the body snatchers
with the turkey president of the opening scene
starts with their straight up national treasure
parody with Rick trying to steal the US Constitution
because like the plot of the national treasure
movie.
He thinks there's a secret map on the back
of the Constitution that will lead them to
crypt of the new world which Rick things will
contain this grand treasure like the Templar's
treasure from the national treasure movie.
Later they use that crypt to completely rewrites
the history of the United States in the world
in general.
When rick jokes about the instructions for
running a country being online.
He's calling the actual constitution worthless,
because as he explains later, he hates all
countries in the universe indiscriminately
in the actual text of the U.S. Constitution
can be found online.
He's also saying that any random person could
follow the instructions and use them to be
a president.
Even though most the episode.
He spends making fun of Keith David's Pres.
specifically just because of their long running
feud use the little RC car to soil the pants
of the Minutemen statues, just showing even
more general disregard for the government
Morty then promptly destroys the constitution
with Rick's gun.
Which seems like a video game reference.
So if you think you know what video game gun
this is based on just right them blown the comments.
Because it does look kind of familiar most
the time.
And they have really cool guns their based
on something for video games while destroying
the constitution, the beam also destroys the
liberty bell way off in Philadelphia, the
beam then continues to destroy the metal shell
around the statue of liberty revealing that
there's a hidden steam powered French assassin
that apparently the French intended to use
to conquer America back in the 1800s.
Which is seems like Rick knew about this whole
time.
The way he talks about it.
Then when he jokes about thanksgiving being
America's birthday or whatever it is that's
just a joke about how inconsistent and inaccurate
the origins of the thinks giving holiday are
in the United States, there's all kinds of
historical inaccuracies about the thinks giving
holiday just in general George Washington
in real life was the president who turned
thanksgiving into a national holiday on November
26, 1789.
So that's why thanksgiving the United States
has always been the last Thursday before December
is another big episode with Keith David's
Pres. he's been in way more episodes than
usual during season 5.
He says the military to arrest them just reminding
you that the president has a bunch of super
advanced weaponry, tech and knowledge of rick's
tactics that they're using an anti-portal
field to prevent him from just portaling away
Rick is also raised the blast shields on the
house a couple times this season already is
the thanksgiving holiday when the events of
this episode were happening.
I don't know if they wrote it as a thanksgiving
themed episode thinking that it might air
during actual thanksgiving in real life, or
they just wanted to do an occasional holiday
themed episode and in really care when adult
swim was going to ask you release it during
the year they do that every once in a while,
but like you see on television when people
do Christmas themed episodes are holiday themed
episodes they try to release the episode.
During the actual holiday that it's themed
after sometimes it doesn't always work out
like that though Rick makes a whole bunch
of jokes about the president going after terrorists
and being kind of a terrorist himself.
You could think of it as a joke about all
of our presidents for last 20 years or so.
Saying that the word terrorist gets used so
much that it's lost all meaning.
Like you just go after people that you don't
like and calls them terrorists the president
then reveals that he has a working phantom
zone projector from the Superman movies and
comics that works the exact same way to apparently
the phantom zone is now canon to the rick
and Morty multiverse in it sounds like they
actually have access to real kryptonite when
he makes the joke about bars of soap and showers
inside the phantom zone prison that is the
same super old joke that everybody's told
in their lifetime at some point about not
dropping the soap in prison.
Because you know both Summer and the VP make
jokes about Rick and the Pres. getting it
on with each other.
Like why you to just screw and get it over
with the vice president also calls rick his
space boyfriend Rick then implies that he's
turned himself into a turkey many times before
on many thanksgiving holidays in many previous
attempts to get pardoned by the president for crimes
that he's committed in the past.
As if somehow being pardoned as a turkey would
pardon him for human crimes that he committed
when he yells at Jerry to be careful with
his answer about how long he's lived in the house
That's just a joke about him always being
gone on adventures.
Particularly when Beth was growing up.
So he only count of the amount of time he's
physically occupied the house, it would be
a very short amount of time.
These live there.
The whole elaborate montage of him explaining
all of these turkey missions intercut with
the president deconstructing those missions
and countermeasures.
It just meant to be another joke about Nicholas
Cage's heist explanation montages during the
national treasure movies.
This time the president plans to swap the
turkeys on the truck that rick will be on
for marines who have also been turned into
turkey hybrids.
Most of you could probably recognized the
celebrity guest cameo this week the marine
leader Cooper was being played by Timothy
all the font most of you probably remember
him from the mandalorian season two recently.
Just last year where he guest starred as Cobb
Vanth, the person who gets Boba Fett's armor
after he went into the sarlacc.
Which Boba Fett then later reclaimed from
Mando is that the whole joke about the human
eye being faceblind for turkeys which they
pay off later in the episode after Rick can't
recognize which turkey the president is is
also another joke about that at the end of
the episode with the bartender can't seemingly
tell the difference between turkey president
and the real president calling himself racist
the president then makes the joke about Dwayne
only being picked as vice president because
he needs 10% of the white vote to win office.
I guess you could think of that as another
Obama Biden joke.
Maybe they reference the giant French statue
of liberty assassin again in it still the
process of attacking New York.
But apparently the president doesn't care
about it right now because it's New York in
the handle it themselves.
I think that's a more recent reference to
New York handling it's own emergencies are
doing things differently than other US states
during emergencies the last couple of years.
The New York state government actually just
kind of did the same thing a little while ago
last year with the whole Vaxxpass thing introduce
Timothy Olyphant's Cooper character.
He does midwestern wife the other members
of his squad are just meant to be midwestern tropes
That's why they talk about being poor so many
times they speak with such stereotypical accents.
He makes very specific music references for
their demographic then references a 30 mile
radius of the it really specific with their
jokes.
Which is just meant to be a generic midwestern
town then they reveal that all the marines
on his team all come from the same area, they
live or live on the same block right next
to each other.
They're all super poor, and they all have
pregnant wives or girlfriends.
Which they all kind of call out in the parody
song that the same for this episode.
There couple different parody songs that they
made for this episode.
Rick and Morty parody songs are usually pretty
good Cooper makes a Doctor Who reference when
talking about Rick a long time ago Dan Harmon
when he was describing Rick and Morty before
season one use doctor who is an example the
whole plot with them turning the marines into
turkeys felt kind of like an Avatar movie
parody with them becoming the Navi aliens
later when the turkey marines start freaking
out, that's a generic war movie parody with
things going off the rails and some of them
getting killed.
Like it's no big deal.
The also kind of make it seem like pardoning
turkeys is one of the most important jobs
that this president has even have a hardcore
underground bunker beneath the white house
lawn for it at this point there are so many
secret rooms and caverns in offices underneath
the White House you could call it it's own
city the president figures out almost immediately
that rick and Morty at the house are just
decoys they've trapped by a David Blaine box.
Because rick would never be trapped by something
so dumb.
If you don't remember the David Blaine box
joke.
That's a reference to the time when magician
David Blaine spent 44 days trapped inside
a glass box was really dumb at the time, which
is what they're calling out here to the turkey
marines are named Rodriguez and Fincher.
I think those are references to Robert Rodriguez
and David Fincher the directors Robert Rodriguez
actually directed that big Boba Fett episode
during mandalorian season two.
Any sexy directing a bunch on the book of
Boba Fett mandalorian spinoff series this year
The book of Boba Fett is kind of like mandalorian
season 2.5.
I will be doing full episode videos for that.
But those episodes won't start till Christmas
at the end of this year.
And as for David Fincher this also another
David Fincher reference later in the episode
when the president yells fight club at Rick
Jerry reminds us about his parents, who we
haven't seen since the Christmas episode in
season one, anatomy park.
His father was actually played by Dana Carvey.
Maybe we'll see them eventually come back
to the show.
The president changed himself into a turkey
in is the second time that we've seen him
change his body for a mission the whole thing
with Rick being afraid of the president in
turkey form is just to make them feel more
evenly matched with the president makes a
joke about poor white people, then as Cooper,
please don't tell the 10% your friends just
another callback to the joke about the vice
president and the white vote.
He also makes the same 10% joke later at the
end of the episode as well.
Rick implies the only reason the united states
is so powerful.
Is because he lives there.
Then they set up the whole post credit scene
with the blueberry's giving cooper PTSD.
And the turkey president swap with the tracking
chip.
Even though they play this joke like it's
a body swap sci-fi horror movie say that because
he got the president's DNA this turkey president
is now supersmart turkeys as animals are actually
fairly intelligent compared to other animals
as a whole bunch of details about turkeys.
They give you during the episode.
Like you could also call this the episode
with all the turkey facts but the funny thing
is that most of the facts the turkey president
quotes are actually true in real life.
Like the joke about them sleeping in trees
in the wild and flying in the wild.
Those are both true the whole storyline with
him winning over congress with the pay raises
every couple of minutes is just a generic
joke about congress being totally useless
in all politicians being super corrupt.
This also an Easter egg in the way they use
the camera here during the scene to when the
super sizing the turkeys.
They pull this move called a dolly zoom is
been used in a lot of famous film.
So you pricing it somewhere.
Like Alfred Hitchcock's films.
There's also the very famous shot from jaws
that everyone always points to when describing
this affect originally it was just used to
enhance the emotion's of scenes.
But in this context the way they're using
it is just a joke reference to old school
sci-fi horror films they reveal that all the
turkeys who the president doesn't pardoned
get sent to another secret cavern where they
keep a mutated version of FDR.
Who was turned into a giant spider hybrid
by a spider version of the polio the president
explains that apparently they use spider DNA
when making the polio vaccine because their
logic was spiders walked more than anyone
else because of their eight legs is purposely
meant to be a very dumb joke they make a lot
of FDR references to his polio obviously because
the whole vaccine joke Morty makes a reference
to his fireside chats when he lights them
on fire the president also makes a facebook
joke when he talks about how hard it is to
have an iconic presidency in the modern era
with the existence of social media.
Just because politicians and public figures
get trashed so much online.
Whereas in real life when FDR was president
back then he was actually fairly easy for
the government to hide his illness while he
was in office.
You could also think of this feeding chamber
and the giant spiders a reference to she'll
of the Lord of the rings the turkey president
sells New York to France, I'm assuming that
after the real president killed him at the
end of the episode.
He cancel that deal and took all the money
back that he given to Congress and they'll
just go naked for a solid portion of the episode
and even the president goes naked for even
longer which I think is another callback to
season three.
Rick makes an inspector gadget reference the
turkey president then pays off that terrorist
joke again from the beginning of the episode.
Calling them terrorists because he wants to
get rid of them.
Then they reveal the president has a secret
motorcycle hidden inside the Congress chamber
activated by Mary Todd Lincoln's name.
She was Abraham Lincoln's wife Rick then reveals
that he keeps spare clothes for the president
at his house in that it's one of the president's
safe houses.
Like he's use it as a safe house before he's
only got spares for himself, Morty and summer
no spare clothes for beth or Jerry apparently
Rick then clarifies the reason why he hates
all countries in the multiverse.
Is because they're only glorified job placement
programs for politicians that invent each
country as if they're only invented for the
purposes of giving themselves jobs the president
also starts taking shots at Morty left and
right to but then is put in his place by Beth.
Who brings them all to thanksgiving dinner
it.
I like that the president is somehow almost
as powerful as rick.
Like he can push Rick around, but he still
cowers in front of beth for some reason.
And I love that he still superduper naked
while this is happening and nobody references at all
Nobody calls it out like it's no big deal.
They both make like they were almost ready
to run to the corner bar, until rick is like
bars suck on thanksgiving we can do that Jerry
is watching a Wizard of Oz remake by Charlie Kaufmann.
And he typically does stories with really
bizarre plots that showcase a sense of fantasy
in the real world which is why you hear Dorothy
talking about real vital organs in the scarecrow
is trying to write his own movie inside the
Wizard of Oz movie the president then rips
Jerry revealing that he hasn't paid any income
tax in a long time because he hasn't had a
paying job in a long time.
Bonding with rick briefly over their dislike
of Jerry then when they start making all the
Nazi jokes with the big super soldier turkey
plot, the Nazi turkeys in space it kind of
a me think of the iron sky movie, but he think
you know another movie that they're parodying
here with the turkey super soldiers, just
write it below in the comments Summer makes
a reference to genocide talking about what
the United States did in real life to most
native American tribes over the course of
its history then the president reveals the
true secret behind the treasure that rick
was trying to steal at the beginning of the
episode in doing so the show basically rewrites
the entire history of the world in America
is actually pretty big deal, so we'll see
if they continue to reference the true history
of the world in future episodes for the whole
idea is that instead of the Templar treasure
that rick was hoping for.
America has secretly been keeping ancient
alien pilgrims and Indians who came to earth
to share their technology, so every major
advancement and innovation in human history
is because of ancient aliens that just another
joke about ancient aliens building the pyramids
and things like that real world conspiracy
theories, but they're kind of doing this is
an aliens and predator movie parody.
Like these are aliens in these are predators
then like it's and later at the end of the
episode one of the aliens literally mentions
the predator movie.
Like somehow while they were in hibernation
after coming to earth.
They were also able to watch movies they make
a bunch of jokes about the revolutionary war.
When rick says training a bunch of hillbillies
was enough to beat the British then they bring
back Cooper and his squad or lease the ones
that are still alive is a joke about them
not serving presidents of the bar because
of one point in history Jimmy Carter left
an unpaid tab of $53.
Maybe in real life.
He was criticized once for being frugal or
not tipping well.
Or something like that if like that was what
they were referencing with that Jimmy Carter
joke is whole rousing presidential speeches
meant to be a parody of all rousing presidential
speeches like independence day with him just
saying a lot of nonsense then they make a
joke about Star Wars AT-ATs and how fans argue
over the correct pronunciation ATAT or AT-AT
the whole thing about them calling out as
unlicensed just feels like the show buffering itself
Like please don't sue us Lucasfilm the entrance
to the new crypt is inside the Lincoln memorial.
And then they reveal that there were at one
point turkey dinosaurs ruling over America
before the aliens came the two vessels that
crashed there were the predator and alien
pilgrims and Indians and apparently they have
the natural of mutant ability to raise corn on command.
Using the corn Cobbs to kill the mutant turkeys
they make a joke about the low level enlisted
men their they are only being there so they
can pay for college in the United States if
you enlist in the Army her in the Armed Forces
because of the G.I.
Bill the government will pay for your college
the turkeys use the Washington monument is
a giant humanizer ray.
Which Morty then later destroys at the end
of the episode.
In the funny thing is that rick says if you
destroy it will have to do this again next
year as if they're going to do another thanksgiving
themed episode another holiday episode next
year and they in the episode with it still
destroyed, so it sounds like they will do
another holiday episode during season 6 the
president officially pardon's rick.
Meaning that he is now pardon for everything
that he has ever done up to this point sort
of wiping his slate clean did think it was
kind of weird that the turkey president's
plan is to only super size American turkeys
you think that he would want to do that to
all the turkeys on the planet and apparently
the mutant turkey wishbones in the rick and
Morty multiverse actually grant real wishes
then they make a whole bunch of jokes about
the president being obsessed with PlayStation
consoles his whole life and apparently maroon 5
for some reason.
His life flash before his eyes, but throughout
history amongst you real world big events
every other moment is basically the release
of a new PlayStation console any ends the
flashback with him yelling about wanting a
PlayStation 5.
Which I feel like is just a joke about nobody
being able to actually by a PlayStation 5
this past year the president kind of makes
a racist joke about the alien saying that
he doesn't speak goo-gah.
He also called the aliens that were infesting
the tunnels beneath the White House during
season three goo gods.
As if goo got is the word the uses for all
aliens and creatures.
But then during the post credit scene they
pay off that blueberries joke.
Where cooper gets PTSD from their mission
and starts acting like a turkey again eating
all the blueberries off the floor in a frenzy
also joking about how the government just
canceled his military health insurance because
they need more money to build missiles with.
Overall it was a pretty ridiculous holiday
themed episode.
But if you spotted any big Easter eggs that
I didn't mention during the video just right
them blown the comments.
My full Rick and Morty season 5 episode seven
video will post next week.
That's the Voltron episode one delete dirly
couple weeks ago, so some of you may have
seen it already on him a new giveaway winner
when I post that video right now, everyone
click here to learn how Iron Man knew about
Kang inside the MCU and click here for all
my Rick and Morty episodes.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!